queen elizabeth und ihr findet jetzt im
himmel wieder vereint sind wirklich
liebe für die ewigkeit er war einmal ein
armeeoffizier und sie die reichste
prinzessin der welt der und es war liebe
auf den ersten blick auch wenn er den
blick angeblich vergessen hat sie
vergaßen sie
ist 13 er ist 18 sie ist sehr reich er
sehr arm es ist der 23 juli 1939 kurz
vor dem zweiten weltkrieg marine colette
stadtmaus der junge offiziersanwärter
philipp führt prinzessin elisabeth durch
die schule sie ist schock fasziniert ein
blonder athlet mit tatsachen und blauer
uniform ein croissant dritten grades mit
königs blut sechs lange kriegsjahre
denkt sie nur an ihn an ihren wikinger
prinzen sie hat noch nie einen mann
geküsst sie schreiben sich briefe in
ihrem ankleidezimmer stehen zwei fotos
von philipp mit und ohne simons bad erst
nach dem krieg kommen sie sich näher am
11 august 1946 auf dem schottischen
schloss bei morrell kniet er vor ihr und
bittet um ihre hand keiner mochte den
teutonen nur sie der könig ist wütend
philipp hat kein geld für einen
verlobungsring er hat nur etwas mehr als
sechs pfund auf dem konto seine ganze
habe ein schwarzer mg sportwagen zwei
anzüge ein blazer eine jagd jacke jeder
strumpf ist gestoppt doch das ist
elisabeth egal traumhochzeit zwanzigster
november 1947 westminster abbey 5000 mal
schlagen die glocken sie ist 21 er 26
philipp ist ein playboy elisabeth
jungfrau er hat affären sie hat vier
kinder
er zieht in die nacht sie schließt die
augen aber sie trägt die krone 73 jahre
waren sie in getrennten schlafzimmern
auf aber es ist die love story des
jahrhunderts ihre wichtigste frage
hinter geschlossenen schloss türen ist
immer was denkt philipp er geht immer
zwei schritte hinter oder neben ihr er
hat keine offizielle regierungsfunktion
und liest nie ein geheimnis starts
dokument aber die queen trifft keine
wichtige entscheidung ohne ihn zu ihrem
goldenen fünfzigsten hochzeitstag 1997
macht die queen ihm eine fast intime
liebeserklärung er war ganz einfach
meine stärke und mein felsen id jahre
wir alle schulden ihm mehr dank als er
je verlangen würde oder wir jemals
wissen werden am 9 april 2021 stirbt
philipp im alter von 99 jahren um mit
ihm auch ein teil ihres königlichen
herzens jetzt sind sie im himmel wieder
vereint und
der erstgeborener sohn charles übernimmt
er ist jetzt im amt er ist könig und
danach folgen dann kronprinz william an
1er ist jetzt der thronfolger sein
bruder prinz harry ist an fünfter stelle
und dazwischen sind dann die kinder von
william und kate in der reihenfolge
george eliot und louis an position 6 und
7 der thronfolge dann die kinder von
harry und megan archie und lilly mit
dana und wie die neue thronfolge die
gesamte royale familie auffüllt das
schauen wir uns jetzt genauer an
ja ganz genau schauen wir einmal
alexander auf dem gesamten stammbaum
hier der royal family denn der wird es
ordentlich durcheinandergebracht schauen
wir einmal auf den wichtigen teil der
familie man muss sagen die beiden wir
alles zusammengehalten haben die sind
jetzt nicht mehr da und die
verantwortung und der blick der ganzen
welt der liegt jetzt auf diesen teil der
familie vor allem auf ihm her prinz
charles befüllt und auch auf camilla
eigentlich früher mal geliebte aber
jetzt dann die gattin eines königs und
bei charles bin ich persönlich sehr
interessant dass er sich als der dritte
nennen wird das ist ja jetzt bekannt ich
halte das für kein besonders gutes omen
ehrlich gesagt die bisherigen charles
könig charles in england haben sehr
unglückliche figuren gemacht charles der
erste war war der einzige englische
könig der geköpft wurde der ein
bürgerkrieg ausgelöst hat und der ab der
für die kurzweilige absetzung der ganzen
monarchie gesorgt hat charles der zweite
er lebte im exil in frankreich und mit
dem seinem sohn endete die dynastie des
stewards also so richtig wehren sich
denn sonst nennen hätte die freie wahl
gehabt er hätte hätte sich zum beispiel
wenig patricia nein er hätte
wahrscheinlich eines seiner anderen
vornamen nehmen können hieß es
karls philipp pater george er hätte sich
er hätte sich zum beispiel um seinen
vater zu ehren prinz philip der erste
nennen können während verwirrend aber
hätte sich ich hätte darauf getippt ich
hätte wirklich alles darauf gegeben dass
sie sich dass sich jobs nennt wäre
natürlich in der redaktion der großen
georgias gewesen wären george der achte
glaube ich gewesen oder die siebte
das wäre im grunde hätte er damit so
eine kontinuität auch signalisiert
hätten gutes oben gab also ich find's
schön also hätte uns immer fragen hätte
meine anrufen sein lasst uns mal über
diesen teil der familie reden weil da da
ruckelt ja ordentlich er heißt übrigens
nicht also begeben jetzt haben freuen
jetzt nicht prince of wales oder ist ja
ist jetzt youth corvo und leider nicht
mehr cambridge sondern kommt ändert sich
glaube ich nicht für harry erstmal auch
nicht sind die beiden haben wir sowieso
gesagt wir sind jetzt hollywood aber für
die beiden klar er bleibt schon in der
thronfolge er darf also wenn alle nicht
mehr dann käme er dran aber für die
beiden und das wird glaube ich denn
freuen die sind jetzt prinz und
prinzessin lily brett und gut dass
feldmann dass das thema die rolle gut
nicht weiter auf weil hollywood wird das
schnell für ein künstlername gehalten
also wenn etwa heißen sie und ihre zwei
kinder als kinder genau das macht also
keinen unterschied also die beiden
kriegen das hin das verhältnis wieder
ein bisschen zu kippen wird das unter
king charles t shirt mit megan und harry
besser oder schlechter werden ich glaube
eher dass das charles eine sehr große
integrative kraft hat stets auch ein typ
der sehr
vergeben kann der auch sagen kann
schwamm drüber er ist ein sehr großes
becken aber nicht unbedingt oder lesen
ist der schwarm private bach ich finde
ich finde wir sollten die auch bisschen
kredit geben sie hat sie hat es einen
schweren stand sie hat auch einen
schweren stand in der öffentlichkeit und
so richtig beliebt ist sie nicht sie hat
uns gerade auftritt in england gehabt wo
sie aus den rostigen sehr darauf wo sie
auch nein nicht nicht nur nicht nur von
der presse zerrissen die mit dem sieg
eine gute beziehungen wir sie natürlich
die presse immer auch verklagt hat wenn
auch die bevölkerung die bevölkerung
ergab berufe usw das ist nichts was uns
noch über einen sprechen also das hier
ist der teil das ist jetzt nicht so der
wichtige teil der familie kann man sagen
irgendwie hier meint im servicecenter
also für die ändert sich jetzt
prinzipiell gar nie - ungern hören ist
wenn die ungern hören sie reitet er
spielt rugby und so daran ändert ich
finde diese vorbildliche teil der
familie wir sind diejenigen die einfach
normalen beruf nachgehen deswegen hätten
sie die alle auch nicht mehr wenn sie
sich nicht so wie die sich nicht so wie
merken in die öffentlichkeit in die
öffentlichkeit bestimmt wie er
bescheiden weil so mccann sagte immer
ich will ihm ist es um last trial zu
sein aber andererseits sucht sie das
öffentlich keiner jetzt reden sie hier
also muss das sagt ja das muss sein über
ihn hier vor allem das ist der
lieblingssong der queen gewesen und sie
hat immer noch heiß ist immer das heißt
es immer es ist dass das keiner nein
aber
also das mit dem lieblingssohn daher
halte ich für ein gerücht ich glaube die
beziehung zu die beziehung zu charlie
zwar immer schwierig das ist das ist
klar aber das ist oft so wenn ältesten
was ich mir jetzt wieder wie das bei dir
ist es eine schwierige position der
älteste in der sohn zu sein und der
stammhalter und dann liegt natürlich
viel druck drauf ich glaube prinzessin
war von
es ist sozusagen das lieblingskind
absolut weil sie auch waren sich
diszipliniert ist überhaupt nicht eitel
interessiert sich nur für pferde und ist
damit voll auf der linie von prinz
philippe und der green gewesen andrew
ist halt ein spiel kandidat und ich muss
sagen dass das problem fing auch erst in
den letzten jahren an als ich erinnere
mich als ich in den 80er und 90er jahren
in london gelebt habe war er so der wahl
ziemlich hart wie man das heute sagen
die hatten ja vor allem mehr waren das
haben wir auch wieder so einen spieler
mit ihm die presse gegeben hat er war
vor allem sehr begehrt ist denn er war
ein junger marineoffizier stellte held
des falkland krieges war und dort
rettungsmissionen geflogen hat usw und
hat dann halt den tragischen fehler
begangen dass die marine verlassen hat
das wäre und jetzt wenn man in jüngster
vergangenheit schaut noch ein paar
andere tier der vergangenheit bei
christina diese ganze familie dabei ist
oft ein fehler dass man das was man dass
man alle man einmal den falschen abzweig
nimmt dass man dann immer wieder auf die
schiefe bahn die man immer verwehrt
marine offizier gewesen wäre nicht in
die gesellschaft dieser halbseidenen
millionäre gekommen von denen er sich
couchepin privatjets zahlen lassen usw
hätte hätte fahrradkette gibt es eben
auch bei der family alexander von
schönburg vielen herzlichen dank einem
blick hierauf den stammbaum der wird
ordentlich durchgerüttelt jetzt mit dem
ableben der queen und damit geben wir
beide zurück zu lisa
[Musik]